Bonjour à tous.
Aujourd'hui dans ScienceClic : Les Quarks
Les particules élémentaires sont les plus petits constituants de la matière.
Elles ne peuvent pas être divisées en des objets plus petits.
Elles sont à la base de tout ce que l'on connait
Des structures les plus microscopiques aux plus grandes galaxies.
Les quarks sont justement une catégorie de particules élémentaires.
Il en existe six types différents :
les quarks up
down
charm
strange
top
et bottom
Les quarks présentent principalement trois caractéristiques intéressantes :
tout d'abord leur masse.
Certains des quarks sont lourds et d'autres plus légers.
Les quarks up et down sont les plus légers de tous.
Ils nécessitent donc relativement peu d'énergie pour être crées
et ils sont très stables.
Pour cette raison, ils sont les quarks les plus communs dans l'univers.
En s'associant par groupes de trois,
les quarks up et down forment notamment les protons et les neutrons
qui sont à la base de tous les atomes.
En termes de masse, viennent ensuite les quarks charm et strange
qui sont plusieurs dizaines de fois plus lourds.
Enfin, les quarks top et bottom
sont les plus lourds de tous.
Avec en particulier, le quark top
qui est plus de 70 000 fois plus massif que le up.
A cause de leur masse très importante,
ces quatre quarks sont beaucoup plus rares que les quarks up et down.
Ils nécessitent une énorme quantité d'énergie pour être créés
et sont très instables.
On n'en trouve donc principalement que dans les collisionneurs de particules
où ils sont créés volontairement
au moyen de réactions très énergétiques
dans le but de les étudier.
La deuxième caractéristique intéressante des quarks
est leur charge électrique.
Dans l'univers, toutes les autres particules élémentaires
possèdent des charges électriques entières
qui peuvent valoir soit zéro : aucune charge,
soit 1 :
une charge positive
soit -1 :
une charge négative.
Mais dans le cas des quarks,
ces derniers possèdent une charge électrique qu'on dit "fractionnaire".
C'est-à-dire qu'elle ne correspond qu'à une fraction de charge entière.
Les quarks up, charm et top
ne portent en effet que 2/3 d'une charge positive.
Et les quarks down, strange et bottom
ne portent qu'un seul tiers de charge négative.
Cette caractéristique très singulière de ne posséder qu'une fraction de charge,
rend les quarks uniques en leur genre
au sein des particules élémentaires.
Cela dit
bien que les quarks à eux tous seuls
ne possèdent que des fractions de charge
ils vont toujours se regrouper à plusieurs
de sorte à former des assemblages
dont la charge électrique totale, elle,
est bel et bien entière.
Dans le cas du proton par exemple,
qui est formé de deux quarks up et un quark down,
les différentes fractions de charge que portent les trois quarks
s’additionnent pour former au total
une charge entière positive.
Dans le cas du neutron,
ce sont deux quarks down et un quark up
qui vont se compenser
pour former une charge totale nulle.
Dans notre univers,
il existe pour chaque particule élémentaire,
une sorte de particule jumelle
qui possède la même masse
mais une charge électrique opposée.
C'est ce qu'on appelle "les antiparticules".
Elles sont à la base de l'antimatière.
Les quarks n'échappant pas à cette règle,
il existe donc également six antiquarks
dont la charge électrique est opposée
par rapport aux quarks standards.
Dans la nature,
on les trouve le plus souvent en couple avec leur quark respectif
formant ainsi des assemblages
dont la charge électrique totale est nulle.
Enfin, mise à part leur masse et leur charge électrique,
la caractéristique la plus intrigante des quarks
est ce qu'on appelle leur "charge de couleur"
La charge de couleur
est un autre type de charge
que possèdent tous les quarks.
Contrairement à la charge électrique,
qui existe sous deux formes,
positive et négative,
la charge de couleur existe sous trois formes différentes
que les physiciens ont baptisé :
rouge
vert
et bleu.
Ces charges de couleur
n'ont absolument rien à voir
avec la notion habituelle de couleur.
Ces termes rouge, vert et bleu
ne sont que des noms
qui ont été choisis de façon arbitraire
pour désigner les trois charges.
Dans l'univers,
chaque quark possède une charge de couleur
soit rouge,
soit vert,
soit bleu.
Les antiquarks, quant à eux,
possèdent les charges opposées
anti-rouge,
anti-vert
et anti-bleu.
Tout comme la charge électrique,
si l'on regroupe plusieurs quarks ensemble,
leurs différentes charges de couleur vont s'additionner.
Si l'on regroupe notamment un quark rouge,
un quark vert
et un quark bleu,
l'ensemble aura une charge totale de couleur blanche,
c'est-à-dire neutre.
De même,
si l'on regroupe un quark avec un antiquark,
de couleur opposée,
par exemple rouge et anti-rouge,
le couple aura également une charge totale de couleur blanche.
Dans la nature, les quarks vont toujours se regrouper
pour former des assemblages
dont la charge totale est de couleur blanche.
Par exemple,
dans le cas du proton,
les trois quarks qui le composent
doivent impérativement être rouge, vert et bleu
De sorte à ce que la charge totale du proton,
soit blanche.
Il en va de même pour le neutron
ou pour les couples quarks/antiquarks.
Autre particularité étonnante de la charge de couleur,
celle-ci peut changer au cours du temps.
Imaginons par exemple un quark de charge rouge.
A cause de phénomènes quantiques complexes,
il est probable que soudainement le quark change de couleur
et devienne par exemple bleu.
En devenant bleu, le quark a perdu sa charge rouge.
Celle-ci va alors s'échapper
sous la forme d'une toute nouvelle particule
qui quitte le quark.
C'est ce qu'on appelle "un gluon".
Le gluon emporte avec lui la charge rouge
ainsi qu'une charge anti-bleu
pour compenser la charge bleu
qui vient d'apparaitre chez le quark.
Dans le cas général,
un gluon porte toujours une charge de couleur standard
rouge, vert ou bleu
ainsi qu'une anti-charge
anti-rouge, anti-verte ou anti-bleue.
Imaginons qu'aux alentours se trouve un deuxième quark
qui lui, est déjà bleu.
S'il parvient à recevoir ce gluon,
il va alors l'absorber
ce qui va le faire changer de couleur à son tour.
En particulier, il va perdre sa charge bleue
et s'approprier la charge rouge du gluon.
Au cours du processus,
tout se passe comme si le quark rouge
avait échangé sa couleur avec le quark bleu.
Dans l'univers, ces échanges de gluons sont très fréquents
et les quarks sont constamment
en train d'interchanger leur couleur.
Cette interaction à distance
permet de maintenir les quarks entre eux
un peu comme s'ils étaient reliés par un élastique.
Si on essaye d'éloigner l'un des quarks,
alors à cause de phénomènes complexes,
les quarks vont se mettre à s'attirer
et ce de plus en plus fort.
Un peu comme l'élastique
qui devient de plus en plus tendu
lorsqu'on essaye de l'étirer.
On appelle cet effet très puissant
"l'interaction forte".
C'est une des quatre interactions fondamentales
à la base de l'univers.
L'interaction forte s'assure de maintenir les quarks entre eux
permettant, par exemple, la cohésion des protons et des neutrons.
Pour finir,
une conséquence importante de l'interaction forte
est qu'il est expérimentalement impossible
d'observer un quark tout seul.
Pour comprendre, imaginons par exemple
que l'on décide d'isoler
l'un des trois quarks qui forme un proton.
Lorsqu'on tire sur ce quark,
pour le séparer des autres,
l'attraction devient de plus en plus forte.
Mais si l'on tire assez fort sur le quark,
il est tout de même possible de le faire sortir du proton.
Cependant, au moment où l'on parvient à l'isoler,
tout se passe comme si l'on avait brisé l'élastique
qui le rattachait aux autres quarks.
L'énergie de la liaison est alors subitement libérée
et elle va se convertir en matière
formant de la sorte un tout nouveau couple :
quark/anti-quark
Au final,
on a bien réussi à retirer le quark du proton
mais celui-ci n'est toujours pas seul
car il est désormais lié avec un anti-quark.
Ce phénomène qui empêche les quarks d'exister de façon solitaire,
est appelé "confinement de couleur".
Il a pour conséquence de maintenir les protons et les neutrons liés entre eux
assurant ainsi la cohésion des noyaux d'atome
et permettant de stabiliser toute la matière
qui compose l'univers.